une enseigne moribonde
les dirigeants de géants nous avoue que
la situation est très critique
depuis quelques années le chiffre
d'affaires de l'hypermarché est en
constante dégringolade - 30 % jusqu'en
avril 2019 et depuis 50 % de chiffre en
moins quasi tous les commerces du groupe
où yoann sont superbes fusion les
repreneurs potentiels se suivent les
discussions et les visites du centre
commercial s'enchaînent et les salariés
s'inquiètent
nous avons eu une réunion hier
concernant le plan de départs
volontaires et la direction nous a juste
donner quelques informations sur les
conditions de la mise en place du plan
de départs volontaires après que nous
ayons avait clamé de réunion on n'a pas
une direction assez bavard
donc en tant que syndicat on va chercher
à avoir des informations pour qu'on
puisse avoir la meilleure orientation
concernant les salariés qui veulent
partir et surtout ceux qui vont rester
mairie à moyo elle confirme que le plan
de départs volontaires est en route
elle ajoute qu'elle n'a pas suffisamment
d'éléments tangibles pour évoquer le
sort du centre commercial avec les
salariés seule certitude le groupe tend
plus vers la cessation d'activité il
souhaite le vendre au plus vite
c'est difficile pour nous nos magasins
devienne effectivement de plus en plus
vite je dirais on essaie d'assurer au
maximum on a mis les magasins en vente
justement pour redonner un nouveau
souffle au commerce et puis
surtout à assurer la pérennité des
emplois
alors concernant les plans de départ on
a initié un plan de départs ya pas très
longtemps pour permettre à ceux qui sont
proches de la retraite afin de pouvoir
prendre pour profiter un peu des
dispositifs et puis partir
tranquillement le groupe yoann a déjà
vendu tous ses magasins de guyane et de
guadeloupe
le géant du robert en martinique a été
cédé l'année dernière au groupe gbh
s'agissant du casino centre ville les
clients se réduisent comme peau de
chagrin
les rayons sont approvisionnées au petit
bonheur la chance les salariés disent ne
pas être informées de leur sort ce
supermarché elle lui aussi mis en vente
les deux magasins représentent en tout
une centaine de salariés